oh
this show is just such a huge hit
Breaking Bad it's 10 years now since the
finale they're happy it's over
please show like pop culture like I
don't know anybody that didn't watch it
it's just like one of those shows and
like is it true that you got a tattoo
and it ended have you not had a tattoo
yet I had not had a tattoo and the day
it ended 10 years ago uh I ever all the
crew were talking I'm gonna get a tattoo
I'm gonna get a tattoo so I just hired a
tattoo artist to come to our our wrap
party and I was the first one to get a
tattoo and you can see it right here oh
okay right it's it's the solo form there
yep yep am I doing that right that one
at first I was like which finger is that
when you're pointing it at me
because I have one I have one on my
middle one how dare you well what is it
it wasn't nice you don't want to know
um yeah yeah he's a horrible man it's
just a reminder to you know don't go
don't open that door you know what we
should do is put a mustache on it a
black eye on that thing yeah it wasn't a
great one but that's why it's on my
middle finger um well I wanted to also
talk about your Showtime show so it's
called your honor yes so tell everybody
about what this is about if they haven't
seen the first season your honor is
about a superior court judge who uh is a
very honorable man
and he has a a teenage son who gets into
a car accident leaves the scene of the
accident which is a crime make support
decisions yes and I come home and he
tells me about it and I say you got to
do the right thing I take him to the
police station to turn him in and I
discover that the boy who was actually
killed in this accident is the son of a
mob boss and I know with every being in
my in my soul that that man would kill
my son yeah so on that moment of of
decision I decide not to turn him into
the police to protect him and the with
the conceit of if I did he would he
would be dead so everything starts to
spiral out of control and that's the
first season now yeah we're in the
second season what happens it ended
tragically I'll just say that in the
first season
second season I wanted to explore what
would that feel like if all if that loss
of a child God forbid what would that
feel like and so Showtime was willing to
go in and just and explore that yeah of
grief and despair and Israel it's real
and is there a life after that and so
but I will say that this season with all
the excitement and tension it ends up in
a different way than the first first and
in tragedy this ends hopefully hopeful
yeah is that hard like I I know you're
an actor you're all acting I get it but
is it hard when you are a parent to do
scenes like that when you have to go to
that place of like what if I lost my I
don't that would be very hard I did a
scene on Breaking Bad where I was
watching
um a woman die in the second season and
being prepared for that and all of a
sudden her face left and the face of my
real daughter showed up and I was
watching my real daughter die
and it choked me I even get a little
choked up I know I'm like I'm tearing up
don't do that whatever now yeah
um and and it it for about two or three
seconds I saw my daughter's face it
choked me up and then that went away and
Kristen Ritter's face came back and yeah
and there she was and and it was like oh
my God and it is it is emotional risk
that actors go through we have to put
ourselves in a position of vulnerability
for that to possibly happen because
you're you're willing to go into the
unknown really yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]